I was reading the headline this morning
I didn't read the entire article because
the headline was self-explanatory and
you'll understand in a moment I was
reading the headline about Donald
Trump's visit to the UK and it said that
the the Prince Prince Charles spent an
entire hour alone with Donald Trump
trying to convince him that client
climate change was real and that climate
science was real and and was a genuine
threat to civilization and Donald
Trump's response was simply that you
know don't blame America for climate
change now I want you to take a moment
and go with me is I just opposed that
idiocy with this article that the that
ABC News reported this morning saying
that climate change could end human
civilization by 2050 I want to read a
couple of quotes from the article quote
the paper published by the Australian
think-tank last week gives one scenario
in which by 2050 accelerating climate
change impacts posed large negative
consequences which might not be undone
for centuries it went on to say there is
broad scientific acceptance that tipping
points for the West Antarctic Ice Sheet
and the seat ice-free Arctic summer will
pass well before one point well before
1.5 degrees Celsius of warming according
to the report the Greenland ice sheet
will melt well before 2 degrees Celsius
of warming and a widespread permafrost
loss and large-scale drought in the
Amazon will occur by 2.5 degrees of
warming and and not to just read the
entire article but I really I really
want to take a moment and put into
context but you you have to this next
this next line is important listen quote
even with two degrees Celsius of warming
there's a high likelihood of human
civilization coming to an end according
to the report the only thing the only
thing in this article that that really
sticks out to me is the is the fact that
there is broad scientific accepted
as well as consensus that this is
happening and yet we have one half of
our two-party system that is completely
dedicated to undermining the science and
doing so for not only political purposes
but primarily for economic purposes
serving their real constituents which is
the energy sector not wanting to make
any moves that would damage the oil
industry or the auto industry or any
industries or the big meat industry
right any industry that is remotely
connected to exacerbating the problems
of climate change they don't want to do
anything on those because they're
getting donations from those industries
it's really that simple but it's also
that sad that we are facing this this
existential crisis that we have clear
understanding over that we see happening
we see we see ships in our climate
happening now we see wild swings in
weather happening right now more
tornadoes recorded in the last 30 days a
record number of tornadoes recorded in
the last 30 days it's there just it's
not only the scientific fact that that
we see it coming it's the fact that we
can it's starting to occur but you can
compound that you add insult to injury
when you have so much of our political
system committed to undermining this one
thing and it's like you know out of all
the things that we can argue about that
are you know important yes but they're
not they're not going to be it's not
going to be the end of civilization if
we don't get Medicare for all right or
if we politicize Medicare for all for
the next 30 years you know don't get me
wrong I need and we want Medicare for
all but it's not an existential crisis
for human civilization so I get the
political Kabuki theater the games that
we play around some political issues
it's a horse race it's a game but
there's cert I mean if there's a meteor
coming to the planet you know and we see
it coming and there's something that we
could do about it
you know there's no there's no
politicization of that and if anybody
actually wants to politicize that then
we need to drag them out into the
streets and you know have a conversation
with them about politics you know I
gotta remember this is oh this is
actually public radio so but but you get
the point
right there's some things that we could
play with there's some things that we
can argue about and play with is not the
right phrase but argue over but but the
the an existential crisis that could be
the end of human civilization not to I
mean I I mean we don't even have to
dramatis Isis right it's happening we
see it happening the data shows it's
happening but there's a level of
frustration when you're looking at a
person who knows good and well that that
the science is saying that climate
change is occurring and that we are
getting close to a tipping point a point
of no return and now this latest report
is saying that it can in that it could
end civilization by 2050 and and and
this is let me read one more paragraph
one more paragraph because I think you
can understand why this why this is not
so much hyperbole they said quote the
warming will also bring more than twenty
days annually of lethal heat conditions
beyond the threshold of human
survivability scientists report deadly
heat conditions will persist for more
than 100 days a year in West Africa
tropical South America the Middle East
and South Asia which will displace more
than a billion people from those areas
so we're not talking about necessarily
an existential crisis in in terms of
like a movie you know people are going
to
this video and so many other and so many
other conversations because they try to
they basically straw man um like oh
there's not gonna be a massive wave that
comes in destroys everybody and
civilization is over no so the way this
works is that when you have 1 billion
displaced people you have a situation
that undermines the stability of every
government of every institution every
supply chain every food chain I mean
everything that makes our system work
when you have 1 billion people
strategically placed not the correct
word but you understand what I'm saying
like like placed in every region of the
globe there's not going to be a place on
the face of the planet that is not
affected by this displacement of 1
billion people and there's not really a
place on the planet that can absorb that
number of people and still have a
sustainable model and so when we say the
end of civilization we're not talking
about mass extinction yet we're talking
about the fact that our systems and our
institutions will not be able to handle
the mass displacement of billions of
people occurring at the same time
because of the conditions that we joke
about today that we that the Republicans
think is a game that that they blame and
say they blame God up for it and they
they say Oh God I take it you know all
the stupid things that are said to
undermine the the fight against climate
change it's a level of seriousness
especially when you have kids like you
know 2050 I'll be 70 70 years old so
maybe I'll still be here but you know
hopefully my kids will be young still
but I digress